i have taken a break from social media
uh
for my mental health because i find
instagram and twitter to be
overstimulating there is an awful stigma
against mental health and i know that
asking for help and seeking help isn't
something that we should be ashamed of
but it is something that is much easier
said than done
tom holland is putting his mental health
first by taking a break from social
media you know i'm really really lucky
to be in this position and uh
i think it's important for me to just
sit back relax and enjoy it
the actor returned to social media on
sunday to share why you haven't seen him
on twitter and instagram lately i get
caught up and i spiral when i read
things about me online um
and ultimately it's very detrimental to
to my mental state
so i decided to take a step back and
delete the app
yeah interest in tom's personal life
exploded in 2017 after the release of
spider-man homecoming
wow you're the avengers
what are you guys doing here
and fans really took an interest in his
chemistry with zendaya whom he found
love with on and off screen they're
losing them i think zendaya just sounds
like that just showed up
very sweet post from tom what was it
like to see the post and i noticed you
commented calling now no it's i mean i i
am yeah i was it was sweet i guess i
don't know
um um yeah no i um i appreciated you
know the love that i got from my loved
ones and then also from you know the
world it was i felt incredibly loved and
grateful for for all of that so you know
i have no complaints it was a great
birthday
tom's decision to peel back is getting
lots of love and support from fans and
celebs online including justin bieber
another star who's never been shy to
speak out about his mental health
boundaries he commented love you man you
should go and love yourself
but the spider-man star says his message
is all for a greater cause on this very
very brief return to instagram
i thought it would be very important and
a good idea to shed some light on a
charity that we sponsor uh which is stem
for stem 4 is a
wonderfully innovative
education program it has um
its pioneering apps
its clinically advised website and its
mental health conferences help
contribute towards
i can't even speak help contribute
towards helping young kids
who were suffering
and stem 4 works very closely with tom's
own charity the brothers trust the
brothers trust is supporting this
charity because we think it's a
fantastic cause
there is an awful stigma against mental
health and i know that
asking for help and seeking help isn't
something that we should be ashamed of
but it is something that is much easier
said than done thank you for listening
i'm gonna disappear from instagram again
um and to everyone out there thanks for
your love and support i love you all and
i'll speak to you soon and tom using his
platform for good is no surprise he told
et a few years ago why he feels a
responsibility to inspire positive
change in the world we're given such an
amazing opportunity making these movies
and we're so lucky to be doing it we'd
be doing something wrong if we weren't
giving back to our community
[Music]